hey youtubers it's Charlie so the big
news is that Warner Brothers confirmed
Ben Affleck is going to write direct and
star in his own Batman movie we kind of
knew this was happening but what I'm
gonna do is my top five stories I think
they should adapt now remember they
changed the comics a lot so these will
be adaptations a really good example of
them taking a comic book storyline in
adapting it is then borrowing from the
aesthetic of Frank Miller's Dark Knight
Returns now they didn't really do that
story but there are a lot of moments
that look like The Dark Knight Returns
comic book so I think that's gonna be
the same situation with these new Batman
films and there's only one on the books
right now but while they were still
working on Batman V Superman they said
they were so happy with Ben Affleck as
Batman that they were gonna do new
trilogy it's just that they don't have
those other two on the book so we'll go
ahead and play this like there's gonna
be three movies but I'll explain some of
my picks you can't do right away you
have to work up to so I'll explain as I
do you know I should say careful for
spoilers from Batman V Superman I'm
assuming most of you have seen it by now
I'm gonna address some of the things
that happen in that because whatever
this next Batman solo film is gonna be
it's going to build on the events of
Batman V Superman so here we go starting
with number five pretty obvious pick
death in the family at some point
they're going to have to tell the story
of how that Robin died now they didn't
say whether it's Jason Todd or whether
it's Dick Grayson which Robin it was the
dive but my hope is is that at some
point in one of these next Batman films
maybe not the first one they flashback
and they tell the story of how Robin
died now there is a lot of Batman in
Suicide Squad but I don't think it's
gonna go too deep into their history you
do see Batman trying to rescue Harley
Quinn so I think if anybody's back story
is gonna be told in that movie it's
gonna be Harley Quinn's they're not
really gonna go into Robin too much but
keep your eyes peeled for the Joker
making a joke about the Robin he killed
he can never resist an opportunity to
rub something in Batman's face just to
try and get him worked up that's part of
his whole thing trying to get a rise out
of Batman just trying to get him super
angry so he'll lose his mind and in one
of those films we got to watch that
Robin get killed they don't need a
hijack an entire movie just to tell that
story they can deal with it in like a
fifteen minute sequence and as long as
they do it at some point number four the
long Halloween deep Batman cut great
two-face story with a really awesome
twist at the end
two-face is bad but there are also a lot
of other bad people in Gotham I think
whatever the bat
film is going to be it is going to be
very Gotham centric it'd be really
awesome if they continued to build the
Batman rogues gallery out in Long
Halloween is one of those stories that
features a lot of different Gotham
villains in addition to Arkham in a lot
of other big places in Gotham you see
like at the beginning of Batman V
Superman because of Superman's arrival
Batman has started cleaning up Gotham
again so this is just him on the beat
trying to track down a big serial killer
that throw him into the path of a bunch
of the other big people in his rogues
gallery one of the problems with movies
though is that you can't stuff too many
characters in or it starts to get a
little crazy in some of the best Batman
stories feature almost his entire rogues
gallery so a lot of the big characters
that appear in long Halloween like the
Riddler poison ivy you might just have
to reference in subtle ways like you
wouldn't be able to do the exact comic
book number 3 also of early solid pick
Batman dark victory kind of a sequel to
long Halloween but it deals with the
origin story of the dick grace and Robin
and that's why they probably have to
wait to maybe like the second or third
film if they're ever actually going to
do a Robin in modern continuity now like
there's a Robin in history like there's
a dead Robin so at one point he did have
a sidekick I don't know if Ben Affleck
or the other people involved in making
these films I actually want Batman to
have a sidekick but one of the big jobs
of Robin is to redeem Batman to keep him
from going too dark and they kind of do
that during Batman V Superman he's on
the right path the way Ben Affleck
explained it Wonder Woman inspires him
Superman sacrifice inspired him so
mentally he might not be quite ready to
take on another Robin he might still be
haunted by the one that died but
eventually maybe in like the second or
third Batman film I think he could get
there I totally be happy if they broke
canon and let Carrie Kelly be the new
Robin technically adjacent Todd were the
ones who have died then if you're going
by comic book continuity Tim Drake would
be the next Robin and I don't think Zach
Snyder has confirmed which Robin this is
yet number two know the big Joker story
The Killing Joke you have to tell this
Barbara Gordon story epic Barbara Gordon
Jim Gordon moment Jena Malone and Batman
V Superman was Barbara Gordon but they
cut her scenes out just because the
movie ran super super long so maybe when
they rerelease it and it's like the
three-hour cut will see some Barbara
Gordon I don't think her legs were
broken in the scenes that they shot so
it wouldn't have to be a prequel and
they've already cast Jake
Simmonds as commissioner gordon i don't
know how dark he's going to be because
Killing Joke is classic Allen more
over-the-top super violence so they
would they would have to bring it back a
little bit even as dark as Batman V
Superman was Killing Joke is probably a
little darker than they would want to go
if he didn't know Warner Brothers
there's all kinds of animated movies
they did The Killing Joke and they were
actually pretty true to the comics so
even Mark Hamill says it is definitely a
hard-r do not let your children watch it
unsupervised but my number one pick you
guys have probably guessed this already
one of my favorite grande Batman stories
one that involves almost his entire
rogues gallery is Batman hush now the
problem with this is like I said you
can't put all those people in a single
movie so you'd have to break bits of
this up and tell it over new Batman
trilogy whereby at the end there's some
mastermind who comes out and says this
was my plan the whole time
usually you would let the Joker be that
person but hush is really a story about
Thomas Eliot that you later find the
Riddler was behind and it also ropes in
Rachel Ghul so there's a lot of
different things going it's a very
complicated very rewarding story if you
haven't read it read Batman hush but as
you can tell a lot of these comic book
stories are way too complicated for them
to turn into movies so that's why I
think that Geoff Johns is helping Ben
Affleck co-write the new Batman film
like Ben Affleck has an idea for where
he wants his Batman to go and then Geoff
Johns gives him suggestions for villains
and storylines from the comics that fit
with that like oh you want to have some
flashbacks with moments - Batman's early
years well Batman year one is an awesome
comic to pull from so don't expect them
to do a carbon copy of a comic book
storyline but there's be a lot of
familiar things building on what
happened during Batman V Superman
because yes they will have to tell a lot
more backstory like what happened in the
20 years preceding Batman V Superman
now the Wonder Woman movie that's gonna
be a prequel I don't know if they've
confirmed that the Aquaman and the flash
movies are going to be prequels but they
could be I'm hoping that they're not I
hope it's gonna be like the Doctor
Strange movie where you tell the origin
story but you do it while also moving
forward in the timeline let me know in
the comments though what do you think
about Ben Affleck doing his own Batman
film them giving he has a lot of power
because he's actually a great director I
think he just needs to really saw a team
around him and I think that's why Geoff
Johns is there with him doing this so if
you want to trust anyone trust Geoff
Johns
if you wonder what its gonna look like
just re-watch Batman V Superman that was
really more of a Batman film than it was
a Superman film it was like Superman
being done in the tone of Batman but I
think that you know as big as the Batman
film is going to be it'll be a lot more
personal story than Batman V Superman
just as leaked part 1 and part 2 that's
gonna be the big theme park ride these
solo films they're gonna be slightly
more personal because you're really only
telling the story of a single character
so you don't have to stuff the entire DC
Universe in there a lot of you are
probably asking when the hell is this
Batman movie gonna come well they
haven't scheduled it but there is an
untitled film on the schedule for
October 5th 2018 I don't know if they're
gonna wait that long
they might bump the schedule around a
little bit to try to get it out faster
because financially Batman is a sure
thing even if it isn't the biggest movie
of all time it's definitely gonna make
more money than most of their other
films and here's the rundown right now
this fall we have Suicide Squad then
next year there's two films Wonder Woman
in the spring then Justice League part 1
in November then the year after that in
2018 there's three films that's the
first year that there's gonna be three
films there'll be the flash then Aquaman
then the untitled film so they might
shuffle some of those around to get the
Batman film out first but they're
filming Justice League part 1 and part 2
back-to-back so Ben Affleck is gonna be
way too busy doing that to work on his
Batman film so I don't think he's even
going to start doing anything till next
year but they do have a script treatment
like he already has a version of the
script that has been finished but they
haven't really revealed what the story
that is yet and real quick reminder
there is a new round of the giveaway
this week all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video I'll announce the winner
whenever I post my next DC video
wouldn't it be awesome if Ben Affleck
just kept playing Batman Robert Downey
jr. style for forever till he actually
goes gray and then they can do a Batman
Beyond story and he will have totally
aged into that very old Batman role why
you guys wait for my next video to post
you can click here to learn all about
what the cast has been saying about the
finale this year Kevin Smith has also
been teasing his episode and you can
click here to watch the Winter Soldier
pick the out of the Avengers thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
that 5 I'll see you guys tonight